all right before we talk about the
super-sized royal rumble i want to thank
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by dr
squatch yes a shower soap sponsorship
because whoever you are watching this
we all got a shower help my personal
favorite pine tar
it's actually just a box because i used
it i used it all
this was one good manly smelling bar of
soap i'm telling you it kind of smelled
like john rambo didn't cut down a tree
no he
ripped it out and then shot it to
sawdust with his 50 cal
then took his sweat and slathered the
sawdust with his sweat
and they smelted it down to a bar of
soap which you can now rub on your body
it has a natural scrubbing texture so it
scrubs
while it cleans it just it was a great
bar of soap had me feeling fresh
feeling clean and smelling great and dr
squash keeps it natural they're all
about not using the harmful chemicals
that you might find in other subs i dig
that so click the link below go to
doctorsquatch.com use promo code dsc
jones20 and new customers get 20
off of purchases 20 or more thank you
once again to dr squash for sponsoring
this video
i do appreciate it
[Music]
godzilla vs kong so godzilla versus kong
is the great throwdown between godzilla
and king kong we've had the movies
building up to this godzilla kong skull
island godzilla king and the monsters
and now
godzilla vs khan that's really all the
setup you need because we know why we're
here why are we here we're here to see
godzilla fight kong gonna skip ahead to
what i liked about this movie
that was cool this was clash of the
titans man this is godzilla versus kong
this this is monsters fighting monsters
for
our entertainment with all the disregard
for human life that you would come to
expect
i think he gets the bronze medal for
that though bronze medal behind silver
medal winner man of steel
and gold medalist the entirety of mighty
more from power rangers still godzilla
versus kong
solid bronze but it had good size and
scale representation you know these are
huge monsters they're enormous they're
supposed to
feel enormous i love it when enormous
monsters feel enormous
on screen you know it doesn't always
happen that way godzilla pacific rim
all felt like enormous things fighting
it doesn't always go down like that
see pacific rim uprising just kidding
don't just take my word for it doesn't
always happen that way so i appreciated
that
the rest of the movie is boring humans
and uninteresting people doing their
boring human
uninteresting people thing in a godzilla
king kong movie i feel like that's kind
of par for the course
every time i say that i feel like
there's pushback in the comment section
like that's how the movies have always
been well that sucks
doesn't mean it's good whether it's
nefarious human villains or
good people trying to be good it's just
like i wasn't interested in the humans
i'm never interested in the humans in
these movies which kind of shows that
monstrous fighting is just it's a great
concept
but it's also at max a half an hour of a
movie
all right how do we pad it i feel like
this movie is like
a frankenstein of other scripts that
were just
on the shelf and they were like oh sweet
we have a script for this 80s throwback
couple of kids couple of youth going out
there trying to find out what's what
because
as she says in this movie if we don't no
one else will
kind of a throwback like stranger things
funny enough that's millie bobby brown
and her friend in this movie actually
it's not just them to hang out with this
conspiracy theorist podcaster which i
guess it's a big takeaway in this movie
conspiracy theory podcasts are
i guess they're just right about things
it's all right they kind of adapted
whatever script that was
into this movie what else we got a
journey to the center of the earth
remake
i guess that's here too sure i mean it's
more journey to the center of the earth
than it is godzilla versus kong
really i feel like that was when the
movie asked too much of me i was like
monsters fighting great
that the journey to the i was like
i can't make that leap i just can't i
don't know i just
it's too much for me like you look at
the godzilla movie that came out that
started this whole thing you know the
gareth edwards godzilla movie
and it's like we had 2015 tech in that
movie
and now in godzilla versus kong we have
2100 tech and i don't know why or how
it's like
how in a few short years did we advance
the tech of that world
by a hundred the tech in this movie is
ridiculous i'm fine with ridiculous tech
in a movie but
it's just such a leap it has to be a
road getting there you know there has to
be
there has to be rules guard rails in
these cinematic universes it's like
no one gives a movie had
conflicting tones like millie bobby
brown and her friend
and the conspiracy theory guy at a point
it was like the snappy dialogue is just
it's way too humorous look i like the
mcu as much as the next person but after
the mcu turned into comedy it's like
every movie that's a big sci-fi
adventure has to be comedy now and it's
stupid it's one of the reasons i like
zack snyder's justice league it goes
against that it's like nah we're just
we're dark and that's fine but
there's a lot in this movie that just
feels like a massive waste of time like
when kong's on his side quest which i
mean
i'll take a sidequest with kong rather
than hanging out with humans but funny
enough
kong is still accompanied by humans so
we're still hanging out with humans but
really this whole
side quest which visually it looked
great i was like this make a great video
game or vr experience or something we're
doing this whole thing
really for nothing it was just kind of
like what can we have kong do
we have two options him sitting there
with his thumb up his ass
or this i guess we're gonna do this i
get that the whole thing was well he
needs to get a weapon
so i guess that's the reason it's so he
gets his weapon
which basically means that kong is on
the same quest
that thor was on in avengers infinity
war but avengers infinity war had
much more going on so it's fine to send
thor out to do that this is like 50
of the interest in this movie is on a
dumb side quest god i'm banging on this
movie so much and i know people love
these
kong and godzilla movies but the
monsters fighting require i'm going to
say that every time i'm like oh negative
but the monsters fighting were cool
well i'm sorry i'm sorry this is
happening to you i did watch it on hbo
max
maybe that plays into it while i was
watching this movie i was like this
movie's
clearly meant to be seen on the big
screen so i get why the director was
pissed like wait h but
no no no he needs to be on theaters come
on so yeah if you can watch it in
theaters
definitely watch this in theaters you
know you're still rocking that hbo mac
so you could watch zack snyder's justice
league again
i know you but if it's one of those
movies it's like oh you have to watch it
on the big screen that's another way of
saying it has a shelf life
of its theatrical release then after
that i guess
what you're just never going to watch it
again that kind of to me feels like
when 3d was the big craze and was like
oh 3d and 3d makes the movie better
it's like if a movie is not going to be
enough without 3d it's never going to be
enough with it
i mean it can enhance the experience to
a point but if movie's not going gonna
float without the 3d then what's the
point it's
another way of saying it's not a good
movie but in the end if you want to
watch monsters
fight each other if you want to watch
titan's throw down
you're going to enjoy one fourth of this
movie i hope that's enough for you and
if it is
awesome but if that's not enough for you
you know who you are the movie's not
going to be enough for you which means
when someone takes
the monster fights in this movie and
cuts them down to a youtube video and
uploads that onto youtube watch it
that's a solid youtube video worth of
entertainment right there but for me
it's not that the movie
concentrates on human characters is that
it concentrates on human characters
that are uninteresting to me it feels
like 25 of this movie is a theme park
ride that you signed up for and the
other three-fourths of this movie is
standing in line which is never the fun
part of the theme park ride but for the
most part
this movie had been a better time if i
were drunk yeah but the monsters
fighting were cool all right so godzilla
vs kong have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you